un avant-goût des Jeux Olympiques à H
encour un Test Event grandeur nature a
été organisé ce dimanche 24 septembre
sur la colline qui va accueillir les
épreuv de VTT à l'occasion des JO de
Paris 2024 objectif de ce rendez-vous
tester le tracé avec les athlètes la
restauration sur place l'accueil des
équipes et des journalistes et enfin
tester la circulation des spectateurs
sur et en dehors du site une mine
d'information très très importante pour
nous qui seront débriefés là dans les
prochains jours mais globalement les
indicateurs sont au vert le site il est
il est très chouette euh il plaît aux
athlètes il va y avoir de très très
belles compétitions l'année prochaine on
repart avec beaucoup d'énergie on sait
qu'il reste encore beaucoup de travail
dans les 10 mois qui viennent mais
globalement on repart quand même avec
plus de de sérénité à l'issue de ce test
au total près de 5000 personnes étaient
présentes sur place dont 3000
spectateurs dans la foule un VTTiste
local qui est monté plusieurs fois au
sommet de cette colline ça fait plaisir
parce que depuis maintenant 25 ans
quasiment on organise la revanchearde
ici donc on c'est nous qui avons créé
les premiers chemins donc ça fait
forcément plaisir de voir les chemins
qu'on a pris étant tout petit et qu'on a
créé être utilisé par les les Jeux
Olympiques je la reconnais même s'il y a
eu pas mal de travail d'effectuer dessus
pas mal de structures qui ont été
montées ce qui rend vraiment le circuit
plus difficile que les courses qu'on
organisait une belle journée sur le plan
sportif également pour les français chez
les dames Lana le compte termine
première de cette compétition amicale et
Pauline Ferand préau monte sur la 3è
marche du podium chez les hommes Victor
corski termine également premier mais le
principal était avant tout de tester
cette nouvelle piste olympique c'est
parcours très exigeant techniquement et
physiquement il y a pas de grosses
partiese grossse montée longue très
physique ou des des gros trucs
techniques qui qui font vraiment se
poser des questions mais le tout fait
que ça reste hyper exigeant du vrai VTT
moderne en fait
et c'est c'est top et moi j'adore ces
changements de rythme et voilà ça me
correspond plutôt bien les supporters
français rêvent déjà de voir ses
français briller de nouveau dans 10 mois
sur cette colline d'lancours preuve de
VTT pour les Jeux Olympiques de Paris
2024 seront organisé les 28 et 29
juillet d'ici là les organisateurs vont
améliorer des éléments de cette
piste